What are those things are called like ENS or some. They stand on the side of a
wall. What are they called? Uh,
why doesn't that? Oh, the IBEX. That's what it's called. Hey, why? Hey,
IBEX is why are you not falling? I bet.
Stand on the side of these walls and the walls have nothing on it.
They could literally stand on a flat wall. IBEX is,
Hey IBEX. Do you have a deal with Satan? Hi,
Bex. How do you stick to the side of a wall? Hey, IBEX,
use the stairs.
The is an IBEX doing dude.
That's the sexiest animal dude.
I swear to God other female IBEX looking at male IBEX and their get so wet that
they slip and fall and their four legs shoot out from under them because they're
like, how does he do it? All I backs are David Copperfield.
Dude.
How the do I do stand on the side of the wall like that.
They literally are just scrunched up against a wall, standing up nothing.
Hey dude, how do you make March of the penguins when you should make
side of the wall? IBEX, make that documentary there.
Taxis stuck to the side of the wall. Little LA,
nothing is under its feet.
How does it do it magic or nothing?
I mean,
some ancient people say that this
side of the IBEX is sticky. Therefore it cannot fall,
but we all know that is not true because I mean Google.
So some of these things we'll have them on the video podcast. For sure.
We'll show you. It's IBEX. I mean, look at this thing, walking dude,
this thing, walking on the side of a wall, the walls 90 degree Greece.
Anyway, every time my buddy texted me,
I've got a buddy that texts me about like girls that he's seeing.
And he always does the slow play and he takes so long. Like, he'll be like,
yeah, I dunno. I dunno if she's into me or whatever. And I always text him.
I always text him a picture of an IBEX on the side of a wall. Because like,
that's what he is. He's just standing in the middle of nowhere.
Shouldn't be and like figure it out.
Anytime you have a buddy, that's like, Oh no.
If she likes me or like hung out with the girls seven times and hasn't liked,
at least gotten the like third base, whatever that is.
I don't even know what that is. Dick suck or whatever. Like,
you know Socrata but also text him a picture of an IBEX stuck on the side of
the wall because that's what that is.
You hang out with a girl seven, eight times didn't kiss her yai backs.
Hey dude,
you've hung out with a girl seven times and all you did was
hold her hand and never got your Dick.
Touched your backs.
That's what y'all are sweat. Char
yai Bex. No, take your Dick out. Hey dude.
Yai, Bex, stop taking her to a movie.
Have a date at home or
yap. Becks. I mean, dude,
come on man. Get it going, dude.
I don't know. I don't know though. You know, I don't know if she's into me.
Yeah. My backs hanging out with her twice. Hang out with her three times.
He hanging out with her four times. You're encroaching on IBEX territory,
standing in the middle of the way. When your buddy, Oh,
what is he screenshots as your baby duties.
I want to see screenshots of you. I don't know if your buddy texts you.
I don't know if she's into me. I don't know if he's into me, whatever it is.
Text a picture of an IBEX on the side of the wall and right,
right to your buddy. He IBEX.